>> HANNITY: IT'S ONLY 13 MONTHS
INTO HIS PRESENCY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GEARING UP TO
RUN FOR RE-ELECTION.
IT WAS ANNOUNCED HE WILL SERVE
AS CAMPAIGN MANAGER FOR THE 2020
ELECTION.
TRUMP'S DAUGHTER IN LAW WILL
SERVE AS A SENIOR ADVISOR.
HOW ARE YOU?
HOW'S THE BABY?
>> HE'S SO GOOD, THANK YOU.
>> I SAW THE PICTURE WHEN HE WAS
SITTING IN THE PRESIDENT'S SEAT,
VERY NICE.
AND THE HAIR.
>> THAT'S HIS SIGNATURE DUE NOW,
THE HAIR, STANDING STRAIGHT UP.
YEAH, I MEAN, I SAW SOME
PICTURES OF HIM.
>> YOU'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR A
WHILE.
THIS IS BIG NEWS TO ME.
>> THANK YOU.
FIRST OF ALL, I WAS SO HONORED
TO PLAY A ROLE IN THE 2016
CAMPAIGN.
I WAS OUT ON THE ROAD ALL THE
TIME, ERIC, DON, WE ALL WERE
DOING OUR PART.
COME JANUARY LAST YEAR I WAS
HONORED AGAIN TO BE A PART OF
THE CAMPAIGN AND EVERY DAY WORK
ALONGSIDE THE GREAT PEOPLE THAT
WE HAVE THERE.
WE WERE THRILLED TODAY TO
PRESENT BRAD PASCAL FOR 2020.
HE'S SUCH A HUGE PART OF WHY THE
PRESIDENT IS IN OFFICE TODAY,
OTHER THAN THE FACT THAT HE WAS
SUCH A GREAT CANDIDATE AND THE
COUNTRY LOVED HIM, THE DIGITAL
CAMPAIGN, THE DIGITAL PORTION OF
THE CAMPAIGN WAS SO IMPORTANT,
AND BRAD WAS 100% BEHIND THAT,
AND HE'S GOING TO DO A GREAT JOB
>> HANNITY: EVERY NIGHT ON THIS
SHOW, I TALK ABOUT THE MEDIA IN
THIS COUNTRY HOW THEY'VE
REPORTED FOR WELL OVER A YEAR,
TRUMP-RUSSIA CONCLUSION, THERE
IS SMOKE, BUT THERE IS NO FIRE.
THERE IS NOTHING.
THEY HAVE NOTHING
>> NO.
>> HANNITY: BUT WE HAVE FOUND
EVIDENCE THAT HILLARY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR AN
UNVERIFIED RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
DOSSIER THAT THEN WAS USED FOR
FISA ABUSE, AND THEY DIDN'T TELL
THE FISA JUDGE THAT SHE BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR IT, AND IT WAS
UNVERIFIED.
>> IF YOU TRIED TO WRITE IT INTO
A MOVIE SCRIPT, PEOPLE WOULDN'T
EVEN BELIEVE IT.
THE WORLD WE LIVE IN TODAY IS SO
BACKWARDS SOMETIMES.
BUT I ACTUALLY THINK IT SHOWS
HOW DESPERATE PEOPLE WERE, A, TO
MAKE SURE THAT HILLARY CLINTON
GOT INTO OFFICE, WHICH STILL
DIDN'T WORK.
SHE IS STILL NOT OUR PRESIDENT,
THANK GOD WE HAVE DONALD TRUMP
THERE.
AND THE FACT THAT IT KEEPS
GETTING BROUGHT BACK UP AND THE
MEDIA WON'T LET IT GO, ARE THEY
KEEP BRINGING IT BACK, SHOWS
THEY HAVE NOTHING ELSE.
THE PRESIDENT IS DOING SUCH A
GREAT JOB.
THEY CAN'T REPORT ON THAT
BECAUSE WHY WOULD THEY?
>> HANNITY: THEY DON'T TALK
ABOUT IT ANYMORE.
IMAGINE IF IT WAS YOUR
FATHER-IN-LAW THOUGH, THAT HE
WAS THE ONE THAT PAID FOR THE
RUSSIAN DOSSIER?
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> HANNITY: IMAGINE THAT IT WAS
YOUR FATHER THAT WAS INVOLVED IN
GIVING 20% OF AMERICA'S URANIUM
TO THE BAD ACTOR PUTIN AND THE
HOSTILE REGIME, RUSSIA?
>> WE'D BE IN A VERY DIFFERENT
PLACE RIGHT NOW.
>> HANNITY: WE WOULD, WOULDN'T
WE?
>> WE WOULD.
AND IT'S A SHAME TO SEE NOT A
LOT HAS BEEN DONE TO MAKE SURE
THE RIGHT THING HAPPENS HERE.
WE SEE IT TIME AND TIME AGAIN
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
THEY'RE SO MUCH AGAINST HIM, AND
YOU'RE RIGHT.
HAD THIS HAPPENED, AND HE WAS
BEHIND IT, I COULD ONLY IMAGINE,
HEAD'S WOULD BE ROLLING.
>> HANNITY: HE IS SO NOT THE
TYPICAL POLITICIAN.
IT'S INTERESTING, AFTER A YEAR
AND THE COMMENTS I GET FROM
PEOPLE IN SOCIAL MEDIA.
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME MANY
PEOPLE NOW REALIZE HE'S NOT LIKE
EVERY OTHER PRESIDENT.
HE'S NOT A POLITICIAN.
THAT MEANS HE'S GOING TO SAY AND
TWEET STUFF THAT PEOPLE ARE -- I
MEAN, THE MEDIA, ESPECIALLY WILL
FEIGN OUTRAGE OVER.
I THINK AMERICA'S ACTUALLY
GETTING USED TO IT.
SAYING, OH, THAT'S REFRESHING.
>> YEAH, IT IS REFRESHING.
KEEP IN MIND, HE'S NOT A
POLITICIAN.
I WAS A BUSINESSMAN WHO WAS
ELECTED TO BE OUR PRESIDENT AND
LOOK AT WHAT HE'S DONE, SEAN, IN
A YEAR IN OFFICE.
HIS FIRST YEAR IN OFFICE HE'S
ACCOMPLISHED SO MUCH.
YOU SEE THE ECONOMY WHERE IT IS
RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU SEE 64% OF HIS AGENDA IS
DONE FASTER THAN RONALD REGULAR
AN.
>> IT'S INCREDIBLE, YET NO ONE
TALKS ABOUT IT.
I STILL MAINTAIN THE REASON WE
HEAR RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA ALL
THE TIME IS BECAUSE THE MAIN
THE TIME IS BECAUSE THE MAI
MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAS NOTHING
ELSE TO REPORT ABOUT.
>> HANNITY: THEY'RE UPSET HE
DIDN'T GIVE BARON THE UMBRELLA.
>> THEY WOULD HAVE TO REPORT ON
ALL THE GREAT THINGS HE'S DONE,
AND THEY WON'T DO IT.
SO THAT'S WHY YOU'RE HERE, SEAN
>> HANNITY: THIS IS A PERSONAL
QUESTION.
I KNOW YOU, ERIC, AND I KNOW DON
AND YOUR FAMILIES AND I'VE MET
YOU GUYS.
MORE THAN ANYBODY, YOU SEEM TO
HAVE EMBRACED THIS.
THIS IS NOT, THIS IS A BLOOD
SPORT THE WORLD OF POLITICS.
HOW HAVE YOU ACCLIMATED AND
TAKEN ON THIS ROLE THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE WOULD NEVER WANT TO BE A
>> WELL, LISTEN, I GREW UP IN
NORTH CAROLINA IN A MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILY, AND I SAID IT THROUGHOUT
THE CAMPAIGN, I WOULD NEVER HAVE
GOTTEN OUT THERE AND PUT MYSELF
ON THE LINE IF I DID NOT TRULY
BELIEVE IN DONALD TRUMP AS A
GREAT LEADER AND THE RIGHT MAN
FOR THE JOB.
I'M SO PROUD TO BE A PART OF
THIS FAMILY AND THE SUPPORT THAT
I FEEL LIKE WE ALL GIVE ONE
ANOTHER, IT DOESN'T MAKE IT
EASY, BUT IT MAKES IT WORTH
FIGHTING FOR.
I'M HERE TO FIGHT FOR THIS
COUNTRY, BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN
WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS DOING
>> HANNITY: AFTER EIGHT
HORRIFIC YEARS OF OBAMA, WE NEED
THE CHANGE.